So
we're going to continue with our
discussion of clinical personality
theories today,
moving away from the psychoanalytic or
depth.
Psychoanalytic theorists are the depths
psychologists.
We're just start to talk about the
phenomenologists,
send the existentialists.
And so I need to lay down a little bit
of background first and I think we'll
start with a discussion of phenomenology
and existentialism.
Now for the phenomenologists,
this is a tricky concept to grasp.
I think I'll actually start by telling
you that something you've taught,
something that Carl Jung wrote about in
the last book he published,
which was called Ms Dot Miriam Shin us,
which means mysterious conjunction.
Um,
he sort of believed posited that there
was some extensions of moral development
past the higher levels of moral
development that piaget identified.
Um,
and there were three of them.
And he said they could be symbolized by
masculine,
feminine to junctions or that they were
in the literature that he had
researched,
which was mostly l chemical literature
from the late Middle Ages.
He said that one of the goals of moral
development or of psychotherapy
with the producer union,
between the emotions and the motivations
and rationality.
And you can see that that's actually
been a theme for all of the theorists
that we've talked about so far,
made partly what psychotherapy or
personality development seems to be
about is the continual integration of
the personality so that the person's
psyche isn't at odds with itself and it
can move forward with a minimum of
conflict at something related to the
Piagetian idea of an elevated state.
So if you're in an equivalent rate
state,
you don't have the sense that there are
parts of you warring against other parts
because you've been able to weave
everything together into a coherent
identity that covers the past and the
present and the future.
So the first stage in use vision of what
constituted higher development was the
union of the of rationality with emotion
and motivation.
And he saw that that was symbolized in
the literature that he had reviewed by
masculine spirit,
feminine emotions and and motivation
bank together in one thing.
So that then would be the united mind
and spirit in a sense.
And then the next stage which was
symbolized again by the masculine,
feminine symbolism.
It was the union united
mind spirit.
With the body and so what that would
mean is that once you got your act
together,
so to speak,
you would implement it in your behavior
so that there was no contradictions
between who you were in terms of how you
thought,
how you felt and what you wanted and
what you were actually doing.
Modern philosophers that describe what
they call a performative contradiction,
which they've formally described as it
another type of of light,
essentially another type of deceit which
is that you say one thing and do another
and it and and it's interesting because
it's not.
It's not a logical.
It's not a form of logical deceit in a
sense because your conceptualizations
are abstract and your behavior is
concrete,
but there can still be a contradiction
between the two,
especially when you start to understand
that most of what your psyche is
representing our Schema for action
rather than for representation.
So the point is is that once your
emotions and your motivations are
working alongside your rational mind,
really that your rational mind is
property nested within them because
that's.
That's a much more accurate way of
looking at it.
Then the next thing you should do is act
consistently in accordance with who you
are.
So that stage to both of those stages
are pretty easy to understand,
but the third stage is actually a
phenomenal logical stage.
You have to think phenomenologically to
understand it.
So here's,
here's one way of thinking about it.
So imagine that you go home and let's
say you set up a room and uh,
in that room,
it's not a very nice room.
You know,
maybe you've got some posters on the
wall and they're sort of hanging a
little cockeyed and you know,
there's dust bunnies are making
underneath the bad.
Then
you have piles of paperwork that you
haven't done and you know,
homework and you know,
maybe there's the odd cresta brand or so
forth lying about when you walk in
there,
it's you in the room.
That's one way of thinking about.
But another way of thinking about it is
that when you walk in there,
you are in the room just like you're the
room when you're here because the room
makes up a part of what you're
experiencing.
And the phenomenologists would say in a
sense that the best way to conceptualize
the self in its totality is what you
experience,
like everything that you experienced as
you.
And so what that would mean is that
there's no difference between putting
the posters up on your wall properly and
cleaning underneath the bed and maybe
making it and finishing your homework
and putting the room in so that you feel
confident and calm there and maybe even
enjoy being there or maybe even so that
it's beautiful there.
There's no difference between that and
fixing up your own personality.
So then you could say,
here's another way of looking at it,
and I do this.
I believe that this is a very profound
way of looking at things.
So then imagine that you could extend
that you,
but it's kind of easy to understand when
you think about it as your own room
because you're in there quite a lot.
And so maybe let's say you're in your
room 10 percent of the day.
So we could say that the experiences
that characterize your room are 10
percent of you,
at least for the time being.
And that you can have a low quality
experience in their high quality
experience in there.
Um,
no,
don't say that you start generalizing
that to the whole house and also then
you can start thinking,
well,
are their problematic places in the
house or they're problematic
relationships among the people in the
house and those problematic
relationships are also you.
And you can tell when there's a problem
because you encounter undesired negative
emotion in,
in relationship to some relationship or
in some physical locale within the
house.
And maybe you could fix that,
you know,
little incremental bit by incremental
Beck you could work on that.
You could note that the negative emotion
that you don't want to have a rise
signifies something.
It signifies that that situation in some
sense non optimal.
And then you could work on strategies to
optimize that and you don't do that
until you stop making the presupposition
that there's you.
And then there's the house.
It's like,
well,
the distinction between you and where
you are is a very unclear distinction.
So then let's say you're walking down
the street or you're going into a store
and maybe your managers aren't as good
as they could be because you know,
to be really socially sophisticated is a
real art.
You can learn,
it can take you decades to learn how to
do that properly.
And people who are really,
really socially skilled have a much,
much higher quality existence because no
matter where they go,
they immediately established a
relationship with the people that
they're talking to.
And then it's not an impersonal and,
and Dan doore aggravating interaction.
So,
you know,
maybe they'll walk into a store and the
first thing they do if someone comes up
with,
helps them as they look at the person
and you know,
ask them how they're doing and how their
day has been.
And they make a little relationship and
you know,
the person is kind of happy about that
because it sort of pops them out of
their persona role.
And then it can have a little discussion
about what they're doing in the store
and what they want.
And then all of a sudden it's a high
quality experience.
And that person,
everywhere they go,
if they're skilled blight,
that so they're awake and they're
attentive and they're listening,
everywhere they go,
they can have a high quality
interaction.
You know when people who learn how to do
that,
learn to do it partly by noticing when
they're in an interaction with someone
or somewhere that if it isn't going in
an optimal manner or if it's producing
undesired negative emotion,
then there's something wrong with the
way that they're being in that situation
and they pay attention to that and see
if they could figure out how to modify
it.
A lot of it is attention and listening,
which is there are key components to say
that Rogerian psychotherapist,
10 attention and listening so
you might say,
well,
so so you can go into your room and you
can identify little problems that are in
your room that you could fix,
that maybe you would fix.
And so then you can start fixing them
and that improves the quality of that
particular environment.
And then you could start to generalize
beyond,
you know,
the locales that are more specifically
under your control.
Because if you're walking down flora,
for example,
and you go into a store and you talk to
a clerk,
well the probability is pretty high that
the clerk is at least reasonably
functional,
so you shouldn't be able to get beyond
their barriers in a sense and have a
genuine interaction with them without
too much difficulty,
but then maybe you're wandering down
bluer and you run across someone who's
schizophrenia and maybe alcoholic at the
same time and while that's a part of
your experience,
that might supersede your ability to
transform.
Right?
The phenomenologists.
People like Rogers aren't making the
claim that you should be able to solve
every problem that you've come across or
even that you should try because
there'll be things that you experienced
that are so complex and problematic that
you might make the Morris.
If you fiddle around with them.
You know you gotta.
Be Very careful not to extend yourself
dramatically beyond your skill level,
but you can certainly start in isolated
locales and if you stopped presuming a
priority that there's some radical
distinction between you and the
environment that you happen to be in
because it's all your experience.
If you start making that subject object
distinction,
which is one of the things that
phenomenologists really objected to
because they concentrated on being in
such,
which was sort of lived experience as
the ground of reality rather than the
objective world is the ground of
reality.
If you,
if you,
if you allow yourself to step outside
that dichotomy and you start to
understand that wherever you go and
including the places that you're in a
lot that there's no distinction between
fixing up those places.
When you notice that there's something
wrong with them and you could fix them
up and fixing yourself up,
it's,
it opens up a whole new avenue to
getting your life together because you
know people always think they have to
work themselves.
It's like it's not.
This is one of the things that the
psychoanalysts I think didn't get quite
right.
Although young touchstone,
it is later words,
there's not all of you,
isn't inside your head for the
psychoanalysts,
a lot of what the work that you're doing
on yourself,
on your own,
on the relationship,
say between your conscious and your
unconscious mind,
but tremendous amount of that was sort
of inside your skull,
so to speak,
but the phenomenologists,
the phenomenal logical approach enables
you to start reconceptualizing the
psyche if as something that extends
beyond you and always will and so that
you can work on it's reconstruction
at any level of analysis where your own
nervous system is signaling to you that
there's a problem.
The way it does that is well,
it's a variety of ways,
but to have the most reliable ways.
Our negative emotion.
There's a new paper,
for example that shows that
conscientiousness is quite tightly
associated with proneness to guilt,
so that's the negative emotion that
seems to go with conscientiousness.
So guilt and anxiety and shame and no
sorts of emotions which are unpleasant
also simultaneously signal the presence
of a problem and so you and and and what
resentment.
That's another good one.
So you can,
instead of having those emotions as
entities,
he'd say,
well,
I just want that to go away.
You can think,
okay,
there's my,
my,
my being I embody being is signaling to
me that something is not optimal here.
And then it's not an enemy.
It's,
it's because it's,
it's something that's trying to improve,
say the quality of your present
experience on your future experience and
if you don't push that aside,
you're pretending it's not happening or
assumed instantaneously that it's the
fault of the environment or the person
that you're talking to.
Then that can be incredibly instructive.
Negative emotion is incredibly
instructive,
but you have to adjust your attitude so
that you understand that it's signaling
to you the presence of corrective
information.
If you could just figure out what that
information is and that can come from
anyone,
a person or a place or a thing or,
or,
or yourself or you don't need to make
the distinctions,
you know.
And so if you're having an argument with
your partner and it's not going very
well,
I mean it.
There's a tremendous tendency among
people to try to win an argument with
their partner,
but you can't win an argument with your
partner because then you win and they
lose and then you have a loser on your
hands and if you do that 100 times,
maybe you're better at arguments than
they are,
for example,
or you know,
or maybe they think more in an intuitive
way so they can't dance on their feet
quite as fast as you.
Or maybe the situation is reversed.
If you in the bloody argument 100 times,
you're not a winner.
You just someone who's beat up your
partner 100 times.
What you want to find out is what the
hell is it that they're talking about,
and sometimes that takes a tremendous
amount of patients.
They should be doing the same thing to
you because very frequently the things
that people are arguing about are only
the tiny.
It's like the snow on the surface of of
a glazier.
The real argument is deep,
deep,
deep underneath,
and unless you listen intently and for a
long period of time,
you'll never figure out what it is
you're arguing about and then if you
win,
the person won't be able to talk about
it and that problem will be there for
the rest of your relationship and maybe
for the rest of your life unless you
solve the problem,
it's not going to go away.
Now,
I'm going to start talking about Roger
specifically by
by going over some of the things that he
had to say about listening because I
think I've learned more about listening
from Rogers than for many other
personality theorists or or
psychotherapists that I've encountered.
Now we could go back to the fundamentals
of psychotherapy.
Mean really what you're doing in
psychotherapy is trying to help the
person become a better person and that's
not exactly a scientific formulation,
better person.
No,
and it's a tricky thing to get at
because people can be bitter persons in
lots of different ways.
Nearly the fact that your people theory
in their temperaments indicates that you
know your way of being a better person
and your way of being a better person
wouldn't necessarily be the same way.
You know,
because you.
It's like maybe someone's grade on the
violin and another person is great on
the piano.
The grades the same but.
But the instrument is different and I
think and that's a good way of looking
at it.
And so part of what you do in
psychotherapy,
and I think you do this in any genuine
relationship,
is not only is the dialogue about how to
become a better person.
That continuing dialogue is also always
about just exactly what constitutes a
better person.
So you're talking about the goal and the
process at the same time and what you're
doing is working it out so that the
people go into the conversation with the
specific orientation and the orientation
is generally with client and therapist
is the client comes with it with a
problem.
Their life isn't acceptable in its
current form and they come with one more
thing which is the desire to make it
better.
And.
And something that you should all know
because this will stop you from tangling
yourself up in your life to a tremendous
degree.
You cannot help someone who hasn't
decided that they want things to be
better unless they make the decision
that they want to make things better.
Forget it.
You're wasting your time and all it will
do is hurt you.
And I should also tell you that that was
one of Roger's necessary preconditions
for psychotherapy and other one was
honesty and communication,
but the person who was coming in for the
therapeutic process had to be there.
And it's a weird thing and I don't know
how to account for it,
but I don't think that you could talk to
someone who doesn't want to have things
be better into warranty,
that they have to come to that decision
on their own.
So they come in with having made that.
So it's,
for example,
it's very,
very difficult.
Maybe it's impossible to do
psychotherapy with someone who's been
remanded by the court,
you know,
because they're,
they're in voluntarily and they'll just
put a wall,
you know?
Not always,
but a lot of the time they'll just put
up a wall and just wait it out,
you know,
you're not going to get in there with a
screwdriver and pry off that Shell so
the person has to step forward in a
sense and say,
well,
you know,
there's something not right about the
way things are going for me and it could
be better and I and someone else might
be able to help me figure that out.
So.
And that's a really good attitude to
have.
By the way,
when you're listening to someone because
disagree with them or not or agree with
them or not,
there's always the possibility that they
will tell you something you don't know.
And like lots of times when people are
talking,
what they're trying to do is to impose
their viewpoint on another person.
In your conversations like this all the
time,
their arguments really.
And they're often ideological arguments.
It's like you're right and I'm wrong,
or sorry,
that never happens
when I braid in,
you're wrong and I'm just going to hack
it you until you shut up or you agree.
Really,
you'll never agree because you just
don't get someone to agree that way.
It's,
it's not possible,
but you might be able to allow them into
silence or anger and but that's a
dominance hierarchy thing.
That's not a real conversation.
It's just all you're doing is
establishing that you're,
you know,
a lobster with bigger claws than than
the person that you're trying to pick
out.
A therapeutic conversation which is a
genuine conversation is one in which
both the people in the conversation are
oriented towards a higher state of being
well.
They're conversing and you can tell when
you're in a conversation like that
because it's very,
very engaging.
In fact,
if the conversation isn't engaging,
then that's a sign that you're not
having a conversation and that's really
useful thing to know too because here's
another thing I can tell you that if you
take to heart will save you an awful lot
of grief and misery.
If you're talking to someone and they're
not listening,
shut up.
Just stop.
It's like you can tell if they're not
listening and if they're not listening,
quit saying words.
It'll take.
You'll just feel like a fool anyways
because you're,
it's like you're throwing ping pong
balls against the brick wall,
you know,
you're not getting anywhere.
If they're not listening,
that's a sign that the system,
the situation isn't set up to allow you
to progress on the path that you're
choosing.
And so then you have to stop and you
think,
okay,
well,
what's going on here?
Why is the person who's listening,
you know,
am I being too forceful and my,
do they not understand what I'm saying?
Is it too much about me?
Um,
do they want to talk?
What's going on?
Maybe they don't want to be here.
There's all sorts of possibilities,
but that's when you have to wake up past
what it is that you're trying to impose
on the situation and explore and see
what's there.
And that's way more interesting than
trying to impose your viewpoint.
The other thing is that if you're
talking to someone,
you know,
I like to talk to people whose political
beliefs are very different from mine
because I can really understand how
someone's political beliefs can be
really different than mine.
You know,
because I got kind of a coherent
representation of my beliefs,
but it's very interesting to talk to
people who have radically different
because they'll tell you things that you
haven't considered.
It doesn't mean you have to agree with
them,
but it's.
It's much more informative to walk away
from a conversation having learned
something that you didn't know then it
is having won the stupid argument which
you can't win anyways,
and that's especially the case when
you're dealing with people who are close
to you,
that you,
that you will have around for the rest
of your life.
You cannot win an argument with them
because all that will happen is if you
win,
they'll get you back.
Sooner or later they will listen to you.
The next time you have something to talk
about or or they'll get resentful and
then they won't be helpful.
Or if you just can't win an argument
with someone that you will have repeated
contact with.
What you can do,
however,
is you can have a conversation that's a
real conversation and maybe you can come
to terms about the thing that you're
discussing and that's negotiation,
you know,
it's like,
well,
what do you want?
But you have to really want to know.
It's like you're having an argument,
okay,
what is it that I would have to do
because we're having this argument,
what would I have to do in order to
satisfy,
you know?
And then at a personal thing,
there's not going,
you can do to satisfy me because you
know,
I'm so bad at you.
It's like,
that's not helpful.
The other person has to think,
okay,
what are the conditions for my
satisfaction?
You know,
so maybe you know,
your partner says you're not paying
enough attention to me.
It's like,
all right,
what do you want?
Exactly.
You know,
you want to talk for 15 minutes at
breakfast or do you want to talk for 20
minutes at lunch or do you want to spend
an hour at night watching tv or,
or like,
do you want me to act differently when
they come home?
And I'm at the door,
it's like you're feeling unattended to
what do you want?
Well then they'll say,
well,
if you love me,
you should be able to figure that out.
That's
wrong because you're stupid.
You won't be able to figure that out
because you know,
what the hell do you know?
So the other person,
unless they want to corner you into just
being the kind of loser who can figure
things out,
which is why are they with you?
Then you know,
they need that to think about that.
It's like,
oh,
what is it that I want from this person?
What would constitute more attention?
Right?
And that's making that argument much
more high resolution.
And then it gives the other person a
chance to actually respond.
And then you have to allow your partner
to be a moron because of course they
are.
So once you've killed them,
what you want,
you have to let them do it badly,
like 10 times because they're never
going to do it right the first time.
So sometimes when I'm,
I've seen,
I've helped people sometimes with
marital problems and one of the things I
often recommend is that they,
they go on a date,
you know,
they take each other away from the home
where the kids are usually,
or maybe not,
maybe they don't have kids,
it doesn't matter.
And they do something that's just
focused on each other,
you know?
And of course,
first of all they tell me they don't
want to do that.
It's stupid.
It's like,
it isn't by the way,
it's not stupid.
It's like through,
Oh,
you don't want to go out and have an
enjoyable time with your partner.
Do you think your relationship's gonna
survive when all you do is snipe at each
other and do horrible things together.
It's like,
well no,
that's not gonna work.
So then they'll finally say,
okay,
well go on a date,
we'll both look disgusted by the whole
idea.
And then they go and it's like,
it's just miserable,
right?
Like one person says something to the
other that immediately sets them off
when they're out in the date because
they're kind of mad about going anyways.
And then they come back and go,
well that just didn't work and we're
never going to do it again.
It's like,
no,
you're so,
you're telling me you're never going to
go out and do something enjoyable with
your partner again because it didn't
work very well.
It's like people don't think about it,
you know,
it's like.
So maybe when you take your partner out
and you haven't been getting along,
it takes you like 10 times before you
have a relatively okay time,
but 10 times if you're going to go out
with them,
let's say,
well let's say you go out with them
every two weeks is 25 times and let's
say you're going to be with them for 30
years.
If you manage to,
you know,
get your act together.
So that's 30 times 25,
that's 750 times.
So if you practice 10 times then you
might be able to have 740 good times out
together.
You know?
And that's an underestimate.
So 10 times of practicing is hardly a
problem for,
for that kind of return.
So
this is all part of this Rogerian.
Like following this path is all part of
this Rogerian process of listening and
listening is trying to figure out what
the hell the other person is telling you
and understanding at the same time that
they don't know.
Like,
especially if they're upset,
they're not even sure what they're upset
about and they don't know what they
want,
you know,
because you can,
you can corner them by saying,
well you want to be attended to more,
what do you want?
And they'll try some weird defense like,
like I told you already,
like if you love me,
you already know which is a cliche and
it's a foolish cliched.
So you can't let that stop you.
I should,
I should tell you the sorts of barriers
that people will put up if you listen to
them too.
So.
So for example,
let me,
let me see if I can think about it for a
bit.
Yeah.
Well usually what happens is if you're,
if you're pushing someone say this is in
listening sort of way,
it's like,
what do you want?
Why do you want that?
What would be the conditions of your
satisfaction?
You're pushing them fairly hard to
clearly articulate their concerns and
sometimes they're afraid to do that and
if you're trying to hash out initial,
people usually have like five routines
they can go through.
One is they block you with some cliche
or they say something annoying and then
maybe they've got one other verbal trick
after that and then once you push
through that,
then they cry or they get angry and if
if you still don't stop them,
they stomp off and so if you're going to
have a successful conversation about
something difficult,
you need a routine for each of those.
It's like just because the person's
angry doesn't mean the conversation is
over and just because the person price
doesn't necessarily mean that you're a
sadist.
It's often a law.
Often tears are a trip.
They mask anger,
so and what the person is doing in part
is they're using their emotions as it
exploratory technique to find out how
important is this?
What happens if I just break down?
Will the person shut up and if the
person shuts up,
they think,
oh,
that's not that important.
Right?
Because they been able to use a
technique.
I'm not saying this as conscious,
it's it's,
it's deeper than conscious,
it's just how people rub up against each
other when they're trying to figure out
how things are structured and so if you
quit when they get upset,
then they think,
oh,
well this thing isn't so important that
it's worth this much upset,
but if you continue to,
well then they'll run away.
Well,
one of the things you have to do if
you're in any kind of relationship did
you got to make a rule,
which is you can leave,
but you got to come back,
but we're not done with this.
You can't run off
because it's not.
It's,
it's,
it's breaking the contract of the
conversation.
You go to stay and hash it out.
So now,
okay,
now I'm going to read you some of the
things that Rogers
talked about.
All right,
so one of the things he talked about is
this
idea called
unconditional positive regard.
Now
I don't think that's a very good phrase
because unconditional positive regard is
one of those things that can be turned
into a new age,
cliche two seconds.
It's like,
well,
no matter what you do will love.
You know,
there are lots of things you could do
that,
that is just,
that's just not gonna Garner a lot of
love,
so unconditional regard that it's not
like there's not an idea behind that
because there really is an idea behind
that.
But like,
like,
like I said,
it's not all new agey.
After Roger's formulated it and it
sounds like,
well all you have to do is be
consistently positive towards the person
and you know,
they'll flourish.
It's like,
first of all,
you're going to have unconditional
positive regard for Hitler.
It's like,
no,
and not only that,
you have a responsibility not to have
unconditional positive regard for
yourself or for other people because
what you're trying to do is to make
things better.
And so that means that the things that
make things worse or bad,
right?
If there's better,
there's going to be worse.
And if you're in favor of better than
you have to be not in favor of worse.
So I'm going to untangle unconditional
positive regard of it.
And like I said,
I think Roger used to,
his word choice wasn't very good.
Here's,
here's a different way of thinking about
it.
So if you're in a relationship with
someone,
and this could even be a very short
relationship,
it could be this sort of relationship
that you have when you go to talk to
someone in a store.
Like I said,
if you get sophisticated about it,
but let's assume it's a longer term
relationship,
you have to decide what if,
if you're going to have that person's
best interest in mind when you have the
conversation,
you got to have that as sort of the top
value in your value heart.
But the reason we're talking is because
I want things to be better,
not better for me,
you know,
maybe better for me too,
but,
but the better for me is a subordinate
part of the better.
The reason we're communicating is
because we both want things to be
better.
And then we both aren't absolutely sure
what it would mean for things to be
better.
We've got to exchange information until
we figured that out and neither of us
are sure about how we're going to get
there and so we have to exchange
information until we figured out how to
get there.
And that's,
that's the initial axiomatic
precondition for a true conversation and
that's unconditional positive regard.
It's like I,
I regard the person I'm talking with as
someone who could transform in a
positive direction and who's willing to
attempt that and who will communicate to
that end even though they might screw up
and you know,
there's going to be things in the way
and the sorts of things that the
psychoanalysts talk about as resistance
and then they're going to regard me the
same way and you know,
I'm also going to make mistakes along
the way.
So
now Roger has pointed out that in order
to,
to communicate with someone in that
manner,
you had to be willing to put yourself in
their shoes essentially.
And he said there you had to comprehend
the alternative phenomenal field.
So,
which is okay.
Well,
I'm,
I'm here,
this is my viewpoint coming out from
this place and now you have a viewpoint
and they're similar enough so that we
can communicate about them,
but they're different enough so that
they're not equivalent and the
differences are actually meaningful.
So now I got a sort of pop myself out of
my framework,
put myself in years and figure out where
you're coming from and that's the goal
of the conversation.
So sometimes that can even help you
figure out where you're coming from,
you know,
because you can say,
well,
it sounds,
it looks to me like you're really angry,
and the person will say,
well no,
I'm just,
I'm just A.
I'm sad.
It's like,
well,
they're all ready.
They look like they're going to bite you
and say,
no,
no.
It really looks like.
I think you might feel also a little bit
angry and there'll be angry about you
saying that of course,
but it led to may also be that their
emotions are so jumbled together in this
sort of chaotic jumble that they don't
actually know what it is that they're
experiencing because it's this terrible
on articulated chaotic bodily state that
is signaling something,
but that hasn't been articulated and so
they're kind of a mess and you're
careful observation,
as long as they trust you and they
should trust you.
If they know that you have their best
interests,
whatever that is in mind,
or at least that you're trying,
that then they can trust you and then
you can help them clarify what it is
that they're feeling.
You know what sort of coming up from the
body and what that's associated with and
what they'd like to do with it.
Roger says,
real communication occurs and the
evaluative tendency avoided when we
listened with understanding.
Now the evaluative tendency he's talking
about is,
well,
let.
Let's simplify this a little bit.
Let's say I'm radically left waiting and
I'm talking to someone who's radically
right way and we start talking about
something like a,
um,
income distribution and the right wing
person says,
well,
let's say the left wing person says,
there's all these people at the bottom
and they don't have a lot of money and a
lot of the reason that they're there is
because,
you know,
they,
they've encountered very,
very harsh circumstances or maybe they
have an illness or something like that.
And uh,
you know,
there's a real distribution of
intelligence and so lots of times people
are at the bottom because they just
don't have the cognitive resources to
climb.
And the right winger goes rubbish,
rubbish.
The reason that they're at the bottom is
because,
you know,
they don't work hard enough and they
don't take any care with,
with their longterm thinking.
And so the last one year says,
well,
that's just prejudice.
And the rate when you're says,
well,
you're just a bleeding heart liberal,
and poof,
that's the end of the conversation.
And that's the evaluative tendency.
It's like you just come away the same as
you were when you entered the
conversation.
There's be no exchange of information
whatsoever.
All there's been is a hardening of
prejudice and you can walk away feeling
morally superior because you know you
demonstrated what a scum rat your
opponent is and how morally upright you
are.
Well,
that's the value of a dependency.
That's not a conversation.
That's gonna lead to progress.
If anything,
it's going to lead to increased feelings
of prideful arrogance on your part
because you know everything and on their
part too and like increased
polarization.
It's not a helpful way of communicating,
you know,
in this sort of thing as we'll see when
we moved into the more social and
political consequences of a failure to
communicate.
It's like that's a microcosm of what
goes wrong in society when it really
starts to fall apart.
You know,
when the individuals within the society
who have different viewpoints can no
longer communicate the whole society
shapes and trembles.
And you can think about this from a
democratic perspective too because you
might say,
well,
what's the purpose of elections?
Well,
people who are aligned with a particular
ideology think,
well,
we need to win the election because our
viewpoint is right,
but then you might ask yourself,
well,
why are there these other viewpoints and
why do things go so bad when one
viewpoint dominate so heavily that
everyone who had the other viewpoint,
you know,
gets shot.
That seems like a bad thing.
So what exactly is going on in a
democratic state and what's going on is
that there is all these different
viewpoints and a lot of them are
temperamentally informed.
So we know,
for example,
that liberals are higher in openness and
lowering conscientiousness than
conservatives,
and so the conservatives are
conscientious,
but they're not very creative and open,
so they're good at running things.
They're really good at running.
You're good at being managers and
administrators for example,
but they're not very good at being
innovative.
The liberals are good at being
innovative because they're open,
but they're not very conscientious,
so like
and that they have to be less
conscientious in some ways if they're
going to be creative because
conscientiousness can constrain
creativity and so for the society to
work properly,
the people with the liberal temperament,
the conservative temperament has to
interact with each other because the
Liberals State Cup,
all the new companies and the
conservatives run them so and then in
the political state per se.
It's like conscientiousness is a virtue.
Although with if it's exaggerated too
much,
especially the orderly part,
then it can become tyranny and openness
is a virtue to but you don't want every
bloody thing changing every second.
So there's got to be some constant
negotiated peace between order and
innovation.
And the way that that happens is that
the two sides communicate.
It isn't that one side wins and the
other side wins.
It's the dialogue stays open so that the
viewpoints can be represented properly
and so that as the environment moves to
sometimes maybe the environment is such
that being conscientious is going to be
better and sometimes it's going to be
environment is moved so that openness is
going to be better because the
environment moves,
the conversation has to track those
movements so the society stays healthy
across time and then the same thing
applies in any kind of longterm
relationship.
It's like you marry someone,
now you've got two brains and they don't
work the same.
It's like you want to have two braids or
do you want to have one?
That's the first question you're going
to do a lot better with too.
So and then so how do you optimize the
functioning of the two braids?
While obviously they've caught a
communicate,
you know there's going to be freedom of
expression and there has to be
listening.
So that's the evaluative tendency,
which is you're wrong.
Before I even know what you're talking
about,
at least I should know what the hell
you're talking about before it decided
if you're wrong.
And so back to the poverty issue.
It's like,
well,
what predicts poverty?
Well,
the sorts of things that the left way
your talks about that predicts problem
poverty,
so to the sorts of things that the right
way here talks about.
So if you're really unconscientious and
that makes you kind of makes you the
sort of person that will rely on others
to do the work.
If you're unconscientious you're much
more likely to be poor.
And so that's a real social policy
problem too because you have this
horrible problem where you have to sort
out what's causing the poverty,
you know,
and who's taking advantage of the
attempts to alleviate it as well as
figuring out.
So,
so that's more of an individual
temperament problem,
which is what the conservatives they're
concerned about.
And then you also have to figure out how
to address it on a social level,
which of course the conservatives don't
like to think about,
but it's not like either side has
nothing to say.
There's information in both.
Those perspectives is problematic though
because when you put them together,
the phenomenon becomes paradoxical and
then it's very difficult to come up with
a solution.
It challenges your cognitive resources
and what the conservative and the
liberal want to do is just simplify it
down to one explanation.
It's sociological.
That's the liberal,
it's temperamental.
That's the conservative,
and so then they have one answer to how
it can be fixed.
We should fix society.
That's the liberal.
Those people should just get their act
together.
That's the conservative.
It's like,
yeah,
well fair enough.
Except probably the problem is
complicated to now,
so there's more than one solution
necessary since it's not even ad
problem.
Right.
Poverty is not our problem.
Poverty is like 10,000 problems and some
of them aren't even associated with each
other.
You know,
like there's the poverty that's a
consequence of alcoholism.
That's not the same poverty.
That's a consequence of say very low
intelligence and that's a completely
different poverty than the non
conscientious poverty or the abuse
poverty or.
And there's no reason to assume
whatsoever that those should be amenable
to the same solutions.
Real communication occurs and the
evaluative tendency avoided when we
listen with understanding.
Understanding.
That's an interesting word because you
might ask yourself,
well,
what do you mean when you understand and
it's got this sort of physical aspect to
it,
right?
That's the stand and then there's the
underpart which sort of implies that to
understand something is to be under it
and standing and so partly what happens
is if,
if I can listen to you with
understanding what that means is that I
get a clear enough picture of what you
want so that I could change the way that
I am,
that I am.
Maybe the way I look at things like the
perceptual scheme through which I view
the world,
but also my actions and if I can extract
it from you,
then I understand I would be able to
take what you told me and change myself
if I felt that was appropriate or maybe
it would just happen automatically
because now I have the deep
understanding of you.
People are afraid of that,
right?
Because of say you've got yourself all
hemmed in with some ideology and you're
feeling pretty secure about that,
and then you listen to some dim who's
got completely the opposite perspective
from you and you listen hard and all of
a sudden you've got cracks in your
system,
you know,
and then you have to think,
oh,
maybe things are more complicated than I
thought they were.
Everything isn't all tied together in
this neat little package that can be
unsettling.
It's unsettling fact.
If you're listening to someone and
you're really listening and you're not
being unsettled,
the probability is pretty high either
that you're not listening or that you're
not talking about anything of real
consequence because if it's important
and you're listening,
it's gonna Shift.
You know?
So there's this,
it's going to set you into that at least
a little bit into that state of chaos
and what you're doing then just so you
know,
is that instead of identifying with who
you were,
which is the person that you were at
before,
the conversation you're identifying with
the person you could be as you move
through the conversation and that's a
way better thing to identify with,
you,
know you to identify with your beliefs.
This is a phd and idea,
or you've been identified with your
beliefs or you going to identify with
the process that allows you to generate
beliefs and often those things are in
contradiction because if you identify
with the process that allows you to
change your beliefs,
then you're.
You're,
you're assaulting your beliefs even
though you might be correcting them,
but it's,
it's,
it's demanding to do that because you're
reconfiguring your physiology and
there's an intermediary period of
uncertainty that goes along with that.
What if they're right?
Well,
that month,
so like,
yeah,
well then what
we'll communication occurs in the
evaluative tenancy avoidance.
When we listened with understanding,
what does this mean?
It means to see the expressed idea and
attitude from the other person's point
of view to sense how it feels to him to
achieve his frame of reference in regard
to the thing he is talking about.
So there's also rogers is very
emphasized is very much the idea of
embodiment.
So you can listen to someone,
you can listen to their arguments with
your mind.
It's a very logical process.
It's of a rational and logical process
and in some sense that's what you're
taught to do.
For example,
when you debate and the idea there is
that you know,
the argument is it's a cognitive
phenomenon and that the,
the logic is structured in a logical way
and that the way that the argument is
settled by is by the exchange of
information and the relative coherence
of the two perspective.
It's a very rationalistic perspective
and it's very useful to be able to
debate,
don't get me wrong and,
and have your mind organized so that you
could put forward a logical arguments
like that's why you're in university.
So to learn how to do that,
believe it or not,
and but it's not the same sort of thing
that rogers is after because when Rogers
talks about the interactions between
people,
it's embodied.
So like if I'm really watching you when
I'm talking to you,
paying attention to your face,
you're going to be like expressing
emotions with your face screen because
that's what it does,
right?
Your face expresses emotion so that
other people can infer what it is that
you're up to even more than you know.
Because if you knew that you could just
tell them you wouldn't even need
emotions,
but what the hell do you know about what
you want?
That's why you're having a conversation
with someone to figure it out.
So you're watching them like mad and
you're watching their posture and maybe
you're mirroring them and you can do
that consciously to some degree,
but it's probably better if you just do
it unconsciously.
And then when you're mirroring them with
your body,
then you can feel what they're feeling
and then you can start to draw
inferences about what it is that they
want.
By noticing how you're feeling,
this is often one of the things that
will stop people dead in the source of a
conversation because the other person
will get upset and then you'll watch
that and then that'll make you feel
upset,
and then you go,
oh,
I can't deal with this anymore because
it's too upsetting.
It's like,
well,
maybe the fact that it's upsetting is
actually an indication that you really
should deal with it.
You know you can't just run away if it's
upsetting,
upsetting.
Something's being flipped over.
That's why it's upsetting when you don't
want to fail out just because you're
upset.
It's like you no clue in.
That's not the time to quit.
We want to maybe detach a bit from your
emotion so you don't get drowned in
them,
so you can use them in an informative
manner,
but you don't want to stop.
That's.
You've got things going then
stayed in so briefly.
This may sound absurdly simple.
Well,
I didn't state it so briefly,
but it's not.
It's an approach which we have found
extremely potent in the field of
psychotherapy.
It is the most effective agent we know
for altering the basic personality
structure of an individual and improving
his relationships and his communications
with others.
If I can listen to what he can tell me,
if I can understand that,
how it seems to him,
if I can see it's personal meaning for
him,
if I can sense the emotional flavor
which it has for him,
then I will be releasing potent forces
of change in him.
Well,
so you can imagine like your brain is
always trying to figure things out.
Well,
let's extend that a bit.
It's not just your brain,
it's your cycle physiology.
It's your whole body is trying to figure
things out.
Right?
And you can't just think about it as a
logical and mental process,
like your emotions are there.
Evaluative processes.
They're trying to give you information,
but they're not very articulate.
You know,
it's like you come home and you're all
angry and you're touching.
Your partner says something that's,
you know,
pretty mundane and you know,
you just explode.
It's like,
well,
they say to you,
why are you like that?
And they say,
well,
I hate it when your boots are in the way
of the door.
It's like,
oh,
that's why you're having to fit.
Is it because the Buddhists are.
Well,
they're always there.
It's like
you can be sure that there's a big mess
underneath that and it's going to be
hard to approach that person because
angry people are also kind of,
you know,
they're kind of,
well,
they're irritable for sure,
but they also have this kind of shadow
on them that is touching.
They're touchy.
So you touched them,
you know,
they'll get irritated at you.
And so
if you mirror that,
if you're listening to them and watching
them,
then they can start to figure out that
they're angry and that maybe there are
two or more angry than the situation
demands.
And if you listen to them be angry for a
while,
which is very annoying,
right?
Because maybe there'll be angry at you.
Then maybe they'll calm down and they'll
start to
differentiate that emotion into
articulated statements.
It's like,
well,
I had a really terrible day at work.
Well what was so terrible about it?
And it'll tell you a little story and
then they'll say,
well,
that's happening all the time,
and then you asked them about that and
then they say,
well,
my boss is unreasonable in his demands.
And so then you ask them about that and
you find out that the person either has
a pilot for a loss because sometimes
that happens,
right?
A real bully,
which when,
and then the answer to why they're mad
about the shoes is because they should
change jobs,
right?
Or maybe you'll find out that,
well,
they have no idea how to say no to their
boss.
They just say yes,
no matter what he or she says,
and that needs for too agreeable.
And then maybe you have to figure out
how they can learn how to say no and how
they have to sort of check with their
resentment to figure out when they're
being taken advantage of.
It's like,
it's very,
very complicated and it's no wonder
people want to avoid it,
but you know,
that's another sort of truism.
If someone's overreacting,
well they're not reacting to that thing.
They're reacting to that thing plus a
whole bunch of things that are unrelated
to that thing sorted and they don't know
what it is and so then if you listen to
them and they talk about it,
they're actually thinking because what
you might think when you're talking is
that you think and then you say what you
think and so you don't have to park.
You could just think,
but that isn't right.
Most people don't really think like
they're not.
They don't sit down and meditate and
think logically through a whole sequence
of problems.
The thought sort of appear in their
heads,
you know,
spontaneously sort of like a reverie,
but they're not really.
They're not.
You know,
they don't have that kind of command of
the language.
And so then when they're talking to you,
they're actually thinking they're
thinking out loud and for all we know,
maybe thinking is more effective when
you say it out loud because my.
Maybe I'm wired up so that my brain
assumes that if I'm willing to tell it
to you to make the troubling that it's
more true than those things I'd like to
keep to myself.
And so one of the things you're doing in
a psychotherapeutic session is you're
just letting the person talk
and you know,
I've had clients,
they don't want me to do anything for
the hour that I'm with them except shut
up and listen and maybe now and then I
can just clarify something.
I have one client in particular who's
very isolated,
socially isolated and this person has
come to see me for a long time and they
just want this person comes every two
weeks and what they want to do is talk
about the last two weeks and they won't
be listened.
And so I have.
I have to be engaged,
right?
I'm listening.
And,
and that's a communicative process.
This snake,
right?
Because your face is changing and you're
nodding.
You know,
you're reacting so you're in the
communication,
but this person just wants to talk and
then they sort themselves out.
You know what?
Figure out what it is they're upset
about and then that's good and they can
go off and operate in the world for two
weeks.
That's all just listening.
Well,
just listening.
Listening is hard and people aren't
taught how to do it.
If I can listen to what he can tell me,
if I can understand how it seems to him,
if I could sense it's personal,
meaning that I will be releasing potent
forces of change in him.
If I can really understand how he hates
his father,
that that could be a conversation that
go on for months or hates the university
or hates communists.
If I can catch the flavor of the sphere
of insanity or a sphere of atom bombs or
Russia,
you could tell that this is a little
old.
It will be of the greatest help to him
and altering those very hatreds and
fears and in establishing realistic and
harmonious relationships with the very
people and situations towards which he
has felt hatred and fear.
So for example,
let's say someone comes into a
therapeutic session,
they say,
Geez,
I just.
I was just having a conversation by for
my father.
I just hate my father.
Every time I talked to him,
it just makes me angry.
I'm like,
that's all.
That's a low resolution representations,
right?
It's like one pixel farther equals
anger.
It's not differentiated and that's a
problem because their body's responding
as if this person needs to be taken out.
Like you might take out a prey object or
something like that or destroy it
because that's where danger is light,
right?
Anger sort of like you're an object to
be destroyed and it's.
There's truth in that because it
wouldn't be elicited by the farther
unless there was something necessity for
the anger,
but it's so generalized global,
it's not helpful.
It's like,
okay,
let's talk about your father.
Well,
how would you do that?
what did he do recently to upset you?
And then you listen and you don't give
the person advice about what they should
have done because what the hell do you
know about what they should have done?
You might have to listen for 50 hours
before you could offer a helpful
suggestion.
Even then it probably won't work.
So you listen and then they tell you
some stories about,
this is almost like the Friday and
psychoanalytic approach.
They tell you some stories about what
their father was like when they're in
their childhood and then a bunch of
things that pop up in memory and you
know,
they start laying out the story,
it's like their land cards out on a
table and they just lay out all these
cards.
There's like a thousand cards and
they're all representations of the
father.
And then they started to exhaust
themselves.
They're out of angry stories about their
father.
And then maybe they say,
well,
you know,
there wasn't all bad.
Then they started laying out some things
about him that,
you know,
he drank all the time,
but he was really.
He always took care of us and he wasn't,
he wasn't an angry drunk,
you know,
and,
and he stayed with my mother and you
know,
so what's happening now is the picture
of the father's getting differentiated,
right?
It's not just one pixel,
it's differentiated.
And then you might say,
well,
okay,
here's all these angry things.
How many of them are still relevant?
Like how many of those do you have to
deal with and the person will say think,
well these,
you know,
80 percent of these anger things or dad
there in the past and you know,
70 percent of these good things weren't
good enough to make up for the rest of
this mess,
but then you get a smaller pile of
specific things and then maybe you can
start figuring out ways that or the
person can start figuring out ways that
those might be addressed moment to
moment in new conversations like it's a
strategic plan.
What's the situation?
What exactly is going on here?
Lay it out and the emotions are a great
guide to that because the first thing
you want to do is everything that makes
you emotional.
Those are the things that aren't dealt
with yet.
They're not fully articulated.
You don't have a strategy.
You don't have a full develop
representational system.
That's why it's still emotional,
so it's like your,
your body and your mind come up with
emotional representations first and only
as you worked through them,
which means to talk about them
essentially strategically.
They don't even turn into words until
you do that,
and that's where I think Freud went
wrong.
It's those things aren't repressed.
Although if they can be,
they're not repressed.
They just never made it all the way up
to articulated representation and lots
of things are like that.
Whenever you're in a bad mood,
it's like,
I'm in a bad mood.
What does that mean?
Well,
you don't know.
Why don't you know,
or you repressing it.
No,
you just too stupid to figure it out,
and so then you're going to talk to
someone you know I'm in a bad mood and
you know,
well,
how are you feeling now?
They'll get all spiteful and tell you
how they're feeling and then you know,
they start to differentiate it.
Maybe they'll remember something that
happened at work and then you can kind
of map out the mood starts to loosen it.
We know from our research that such
empathic understanding,
understanding with a person,
knowing about him is such an effective
approach that it can bring about major
changes in personality.
Some of you may be feeling that you
listen well to people and that you have
never seen such results.
The chances are very great indeed that
you're listening has not been of the
type I have described.
Fortunately,
I can suggest a little laboratory
experiment which you can try to test the
quality of your understanding.
Okay,
so this is.
This is lovely because you don't often
actually get it.
Tell me from a therapist that actually
work,
you know,
you get sort of vague techniques like
help the person lay the cards out on the
table.
You know,
it's,
it's kind of at a high level of
abstraction,
but this exercise you can actually do
and you can do it a lot and if you do it
and we'll teach you,
listen.
So
the next time you get into an argument
with your wife or your friends or with a
small group of friends,
start the discussion for a moment and
for an experiment institute this rule,
while you also don't have to be that
formal about it,
you can just do it.
Once you know the the team,
each person can speak up for himself
only after he is first restated the
ideas and feelings of the previous
speaker accurately
and to that speaker satisfaction.
Now,
that's so cool because here's the
typical argument,
so we're arguing,
I want to win,
and so you're telling me a bunch of
things,
and so then I take those things that I
turned them into the stupidest possible
representation of those things.
You know I wake in your argument and
make you look like a fool and then
destroy it and that's a strong.
That's fine that you're making your
opponent into a straw man Max.
The Straw man argument,
right?
You take,
you take what they're telling you and
your caricatured and that way you can
make them look absurd and make them be
ashamed.
And then of course you've set up this
skinny little opponent that you can just
demolish with one punch.
It's really crooked and it shows that
you're a coward because what it means is
you have to have an opponent that's
crippled in and thin and starving and
and inarticulate before you could
possibly win,
before you could possibly progress.
It's a pathetic way of having an
argument.
What you should do is listen to the
person and help them make their argument
as strong as you possibly can and then
deal with that because then you're sure
that you're,
you're taking them seriously.
So,
and to that speaker satisfaction.
Well,
that's so cool.
Okay,
so we're,
we're having an argument.
Well,
I don't know.
Maybe we'll have an argument about who's
gonna be responsible for grocery
shopping or for doing the dishes or for
cooking or any of those domestic things
that continually caused couples to be at
each other's throat.
It's like,
so you'll have some arguments about you
should do whatever it is that you're
going to do and in order for the
argument to progress,
I have to tell you back what you said
and you have to agree that I put it
properly.
Well,
that's so annoying.
Like it just runs so contrary to what
you want to do because of course you
want to make another person sounds
stupid so you could meet them this way.
You can't do that because you have to
listen well enough so you actually
understood what they said and then you
have to formulate their argument so that
they're willing to agree that that
actually constitutes their argument.
Well,
that's really,
it's difficult,
but it's so useful because first of all,
it does mean that you understood them
and second immediately indicates to them
that you're not just trying to,
when you're trying to listen and then
they're much less likely to get all
irritable and angry at you because at
least you're trying to listen.
You're not making them into a fool.
And you know often when people are
trying to tell you what they want
because they're all afraid of telling
you what they want because you know,
maybe they never got what they wanted in
their whole life.
You know,
if they've had a history of bad
relationships with poor parenting and
that sort of thing,
you're just blooded terrified to tell
you that they actually want something
and so as soon as you indicate to them
that you actually heard what they said
and you're willing to take it seriously
enough to formulate it properly,
well then it's like one step towards
trust.
I see you didn't listen.
You at least know where I'm coming from.
It's like,
that doesn't mean you agree.
You know,
just because you understand someone's
argument doesn't mean you have to agree,
but at least you know what the argument
is.
You see what this would mean.
So one of the things,
Roger's got us continually his therapy
and I do this a lot.
It's like I listen to the person and
they kind of go through a narrative at
spontaneous narrative,
often following a chain of associations
as pointed out,
you'll come you spontaneous narrative
and I'll say,
okay,
it sounds to me like this is what you
said,
and I'll try to lay out the argument and
maybe now and then I'll,
I'll ask for clarification if there's a
part I didn't understand or if I see
that there's a part that seems
contradictory,
you know,
they said this thing here,
this thing there,
and I don't tell them that,
you know,
seems to me that you said this here and
this here.
I'm not sure how to put those together.
I don't say,
well,
that makes your argument,
you know,
incoherent.
I say,
well,
I don't get how to understand that.
And they go,
oh yeah,
there is.
Because people will admit to that if you
just pointed out flatly.
No.
It's like,
I'm not involved.
I'm just listening.
It's not my problem.
It's a problem.
And that's another thing that's useful
to the other person is entitled to their
suffering.
You don't get to take it away.
It's their destiny so you can listen to
their problems without having to think
that you know you have to take them on
as if they're yours.
You have to mirror them like it's their
problem.
It's like they have to figure it out and
they and that's good.
You need a problem to figure out.
It's not necessarily a terrible thing
that they have a problem.
It would simply mean that before
presenting your own point of view,
it would be necessary for you to really
achieve the other speakers frame of
reference to understand his thoughts and
feeling so well that you could summarize
them for him.
And that's useful too because you know
the way we remember things is if you
tell me a long story and I tell it back
to you,
I do not tell it back to you.
What happens is I listened to it and I
try to figure out what the thread of the
argument is and then when I dial it back
to you,
it's way shorter and tighter and that
means in some sense it's,
it's got all the essentials,
but it's got less of the baggage.
Right?
That's what you're kind of doing when
you ask someone to get to the point,
so they tell you this long story,
it's like this tree that is full of dead
branches and it hasn't been proved and
they're extending their and you know,
the maybe the living branches you can
hardly even see,
but you're concentrating on them and
then when you tell it back to them,
you just tell them the part of the story
that's alive and they listened to that
and they think,
Oh yes,
that's what I meant,
and then that means you've changed the
memory,
right?
If they have,
you've changed the memory,
you've,
you've divested of all the excess
baggage,
just like pruning and that's what you're
doing.
And so that a dialogue is mental hygiene
and that's what people do.
You know,
you've got to wonder,
well,
why don't we talk?
Well,
it's to exchange information.
Yeah,
there's utility in it.
You know,
like if you know how to do something and
I don't,
you can tell me,
but that,
that isn't the sort of thing that people
are doing most of the time.
Most of the time they're telling their
stories,
this is what happened to me right in
there,
and then not a person will say,
well,
this is what happened to me,
and there's this mutual attempt to
organize.
That's how people are organizing their
brains.
We organized our brains by talking,
and so if you don't have someone to
listen to you,
well,
especially if it's over a few decades,
you're going to have a brain that's like
a whole forest of trees that it needs.
A forest fire doesn't need just some,
you know,
trim and it's really in trouble.
So you need to have someone to listen to
you and best way to hit someone like
that is to find a bunch of people and
listen to them because you know,
of course then now that's a friendship.
That's a real friendship,
you know,
because you're both trying to move
towards a better place.
Whatever that place is,
and it's a great relationship.
Then sounds simple,
doesn't it?
But if you try it,
you'll discover it's one of the most
difficult things you've ever tried to
do.
However,
once you've been able to see the other
person's point of view,
your own comments will have to be
drastically revised.
Well,
that's partly because now there are sort
of vague complaints is tightened up to a
specific problem.
Then you have to reconfigure how you're
responding to address that problem.
You also find the emotion going on with
the discussion,
the differences being reduced and those
differences which remain being on a
rational and understandable sort.
If you were really willing to understand
a person in this way,
if you're willing to answer their
private world and see the like the way
their life appears to them,
you run the risk of being changed
yourself,
which is good.
That's a good thing.
If you're involved in a real
conversation,
the way that you will change will be
beneficial to you,
but it's.
But it's,
it's a challenging thing because it will
mean that you can't stick to the little,
you know,
rigid framework that you had entering
into the argument.
You have to loosen that up and be
willing to open the door and you know,
change the walls of your house.
You might see it his way.
That wouldn't be good.
You might find yourself influenced or
you're in your attitudes or personality.
The risk of being changed is one of the
most frightening prospects most of us
can face.
Well,
imagine so when you're trying to build
yourself into high fully fledged you.
Well,
here's one way of doing it.
Just hang around with people like you
who think the same way you do and then
whenever you talk they just reflect back
what you have to say.
Or you can start putting yourself in
situations that you're uncomfortable
with,
you know,
pushing yourself a little bit and you go
out where there are people that aren't
like you and then you think,
well,
how am I going to get to understand
these people?
And the first thing you do is you got to
pay attention and you got to listen and
then maybe you'll be able to interact
with them and then who.
That's another environment that you've
mastered and then there's more of you
because now you can operate here and
here.
And then maybe you think,
well that was kind of fun.
So now I'll go here and we'll try this,
and you go there and you listened and
you pay attention and all of a sudden
bang,
you can operate there and if you do that
over like a 15 year period,
you'll be someone who could go anywhere
and not fit in exactly that.
That's like you're invisible.
It's not like you're fitting.
Yes.
It's like you can operate there,
you can talk and listen.
You can gather information,
you can trade your useful there and then
you're not gonna run up against people
and you know,
risk,
unnecessary conflict.
Because if you listen to people,
you just cannot believe what people will
tell you if you listen to them.
It is absolutely.
And you can.
If you can listen to people,
they will tell you profound things so
fast that it just makes your head spin.
You know,
because people are really weird
creatures.
They're like Dostoyevsky characters
there.
There are peculiar.
They think in weird ways and they have
weird experiences and bizarre dreams and
ideas about the future political
theories.
They're just as crazy as you could
possibly imagine.
And if you listen to them,
they'll tell you why they think these
things and it's.
It's not boring.
That's another issue is if the
conversation is boring,
you are not listening because if you're
listening,
the conversation will change so that it
won't be boring.
So you can tell if you're in a
conversation that's foreign,
you're someone at least is not listening
and it could easily be you.
If I enter as fully as I enabled into
the private world of the neurotic or
psychotic individual,
isn't there a risk that I might become
lost in that world?
Most of us are afraid to take that risk.
The great majority of us cannot listen.
We found ourselves,
we find ourselves compelled to evaluate,
and the evaluation is,
I'm going to keep you away.
I'm going to pigeonhole you,
classify you.
Make the classification negative.
Describe you as irrelevant and push you
aside because then I don't have to pay
attention.
I don't have to listen and I can stay in
my box of certainty,
my little narrow box of certainty.
The great majority of us cannot listen.
We find ourselves to pell to evaluate
because listening is too dangerous.
The first requirement is courage and we
do not always have it.
Okay.
So Carl Rogers,
he's a phenomenologist.
So think it's your experience that's
real.
You need to represent that experience
and you need to communicate it to other
people and you have to communicate it
within a frame.
And the proper frame is we're trying to
make things better here and you know,
in order to adopt that frame,
that's not just a simple statement,
right?
I mean you can tell yourself that,
try to put yourself in that state of
mind.
But to do that you have to really think
through your heart.
You have to decide like,
what are you up to?
Are you here to make things worse or are
you here to make things better?
And you know,
you might say,
well clearly I'm here to make things
better.
It's like,
yeah,
sure,
no,
that's hard and people are full of
resentment and fear and anger and they'd
be hurt and all sorts of ways that they
want to take revenge and like they're
just full of contradictory impulses.
And so to weave all those contradictory
impulses together to overcome all those
hurts and disappointments in and reasons
for revenge and resentment,
you have to do all that before you can
say,
well,
I'm here to make things better.
Because if you're still possessed by
those sorts of experiences and
contradictions,
you're going to be motivated to make
things worse all the time,
just out of revenge and spite you know
you.
You've been hurt,
you're going to hurt,
and so do adopt.
The framework that Rogers is talking
about is it's difficult enterprise and
partly it'll come about the more you
listen because the more you listen,
you have the chance to exchange
information,
the more you will deal with those inner
contradictions in that sort of
collection of hurts and irritations
that,
that are corrupting you in twisted you
in the wrong direction.
So the rigid perspective is extremely
useful.
It's very useful.
The reason I concentrated on that one
quote of his today is because it's such
a useful thing,
you can try right away the next time
you're talking to someone,
maybe have a friend who wants to talk
things over.
It's like listen to them and then when
there's a pause say,
well,
it sounds to me like this is what you
meant,
and they'll go,
yes,
that's exactly what I meant.
Maybe if you were really listening,
they'll be real happy about that because
they didn't know what they meant.
They're just telling you the story about
why they're annoying and so then you'll
think,
oh wow,
I got it,
and then there'll be happy and they'll
tell you something else and like they'll
walk away from that conversation much
lighter and you will too.
Even though it's a weird thing because
you might think,
well if you listen,
people are going to dump a bunch of
trouble on you.
It's like,
well,
yes,
but if you're willing to listen despite
the fact that there might be a bunch of
trouble dumped on you,
then you've also pulled yourself that
you're the sort of person who can
tolerate having a bunch of trouble
dumped on yourself and that's like,
that's.
That's an extremely positive attitude to
take towards yourself.
You don't want.
You're not just saying you're acting it
out,
and so that's a sign of faith in
yourself and you're not.
Well.
I said you were stupid like you are in
relationships,
but you're not totally stupid.
You know,
you'll be able to notice that you,
you,
you've been willing to expose yourself
to a risk and when your body and your
mind you're watching that,
they'll think,
oh,
I'm the sort of thing that can
voluntarily expose itself to a risk.
Well,
that's like the secrets to making
yourself strong.
It's exposure and so you can do that in
every conversation and that toughens you
up as well as informing you.
It's a very powerful technique,
so I would recommend try it,
see what happens.
It's really,
it's also fun because it's like you're
following a thread of the conversation.
If you're really listening to the
conversation will continue and it
continues in a meaningful way and then
you know that you're in the right place
and it's like a challenge to your
capacity to pay attention and then you
get engaged in the convert.
All conversations.
You get engaged in them and then you're
in engaging conversations all the time.
That's a good thing,
so.
Okay,
we'll see you.